One more thing you may be wondering is,
how does the term Data Analysis relate
to similar terms like Data Science,
Data Engineering or Big Data?
First, Data Science is very
similar to Data Analysis.
In fact, many people might describe
some of the examples I gave near
the beginning of the lesson,
such as Netflix's movie
recommendations as data science.
I often hear people use the terms,
data analysis and
data science interchangeably.
However, to the extent that
there is a difference.
In my experience data science
is a little more likely to refer
to building some sort of a system,
like a recommendation system, or
a ranking algorithm.
While a blog post or
a paper is more likely to be
refered to as data analysis.
It's definitely a fuzzy line though.
If you hear some advice for a data
scientists, it's probably relevant for
a data analyst as well.
In terms of job postings, a data
scientist title sometimes requires more
experience than a data analyst title.
Although of course
this varies by company.
Data engineers are more focused
on the data wrangling step of
the data analysis process.
They make data pipelines and insure that
data collection is fault tolerant and
scales well.
They're more involved in storing and
processing data, and
less involved in drawing
conclusions based on the data.
Big data is a fuzzy term that refers
to the fact that many companies
today are dealing with a lot of data,
terabytes, petabytes, and more.
There's no rule for how much data you
need before it is big, but certainly
the amount of data we have today
seems big compared to ten years ago.
Data analysts, data scientists, and
data engineers can all work with
either big data or not so big data.